our welcome to this video is a slight
technical issue this is why I lost a
couple of seconds are playing the raven
from Iceland whoever symmetrical English
on the boat let's see Miss killing g6
they're probably we got to we get amarok
see point if it takes yep
yeah this is the main line of them Roxy
Bishop d7 may move now I can also take
on d4 let's see yellow black has some
other moves like a six and rook e8 the
late danish legend bent Lars was a great
expert on the black side of this and he
has played all kinds of moves in this
position another big expert for the
black side is the Icelandic Grandmaster
magia pitocin he is some problem yeah
played more games with them Roxy then
than anyone else maybe besides Lawson
he's a retired player though he doesn't
play competitive chess anymore and
became the CEO of one of the major banks
in Iceland so maybe he's one of the
wealthiest chess players around okay
I'll form chess players let's see and he
he was a became the CEO of one of the
bank that didn't really run into much
trouble in the financial crisis uhm Jung
might too before I don't really want to
take
keep pieces on the board yep I don't I
don't write this is in fact a nice
square a constant issue in the MER oxy
for black is that you would like to
exchange some pieces and sometimes you
don't manage until you suffer from the
lack of space like to get get the look
at all of the diagonal this is always
useful yeah this is a position where
he'd like to exchange some pieces he
sort of has more than one piece for
instance for the d7 square one pair of
knights traded his help would be helpful
yeah looking for come to play
yeah maybe you sometimes you can switch
the twin over 2 h8 okay let's see is
there form I forces simpleton yeah well
not really I can play age 38 f 4
just one one possible way to play there
are many interesting options also 95 for
example play on the queenside or roxy 1
preparing that yeah yeah I must admit
that I'm I am really liked this opening
public i played it once in a while as
black but they didn't have much success
it's just um not so comfortable to play
always having less space and maneuvering
on the back Rankin hmm you why can't
play a for now energy for looks looks
like it looks a week
I can one prepare that but what I what
does respond what is what is his
response actually can play night see
fire button that I have f4 Bishop f3h
five is not really helping I just
recognize that she's got Knight f6 now
yeah I didn't time that right I should
have should have played this a bit a bit
more slowly 96 knows a bit bit
uncomfortable hmm I'm maybe night f65 I
can play five yeah after that is a
different story I forgot about this idea
this is good I five Wow
hmmmm okay yeah well I can't need to
take what and now I can take on c6 play
94 which means he would he would need to
give up his Bishop our weight I can also
know hmm now come on come on let's do
that not spend ages on this move
I wonder if he takes if I should
recapture with the Queen actually you
know keeping keeping this protected at
for me yeah
chief i might play you five I want to
prevent you five keeping putting
pressure on d6 this isn't so terrible
for black really
now if I've I can retreat and sorry I
can take g6 I can take 26 so let's see
if I've I can still take after its
capture I want every gauge one
wow it's going right into that check wow
this is quite accommodating let's see
I'll g5g five night h5 is not a
convincing and he's got a five ok least
he cannot take how to how to get ahead
here
hmm he's got a five coming but I can I
can probably just take it
if I'm taking these six and i want to
play Bishop defines the idea
then there certainly was something
better readable
yeah multi5 was probably a mistake this
looks like very nice for what the bishop
on the long diagonal g5 it's just just
just as strong black resigned yeah it I
didn't really play this convincingly
here I mean after that after he opens up
the H file it looks like a disaster but
I didn't really refute it and the
compass only on +1 amazingly check get
even wants to play row gauge form I play
all the kongorfs at spooky
yeah and that's over yeah they really
defended defended well at five maybe add
some some other way to play here maybe
the stint really if this didn't really
work out so well 95 s is another option
just putting it in the center and this
is an eternal problem in the MER oxy
bind or any dragon type structure the
night appearing on d5 it can only
expelled can only be expelled with e6
mostly and this just weakens the whole
structure maybe this is better this this
is not so terrible for black ian maybe
also 96 as a move here he's got this
slightly weakened king but it seems
playable it only really God's got tricky
after he took coming this is really a
bit a bit strange this decision alright
an interesting game nevertheless thanks
for watching